eco de explosiones en la franja de gaza
es el sonido de los bombardeos de Israel
una respuesta a los cohetes lanzados en
horas previas desde el enclave palestino
sin embargo esos cohetes sobre el cielo
de la ciudad de asherón Fueron
interceptados por el sistema de defensa
israelí una noche turbulenta después de
una matanza en Jordania el jueves el
ejército israelí asaltó un campamento de
refugiados palestinos en yenín al norte
se trata de una de las operaciones de
este tipo más mortíferas en cerca de dos
décadas nueve muertos avala Incluyendo a
dos civiles una víctima era una mujer de
61 años las autoridades palestinas lo
describen como una masacre de otra parte
Israel asegura que sus efectivos
atacaron una célula de la yihad islámica
mientras investigan los reportes de los
civiles fallecidos Quiero felicitar a
las fuerzas antiterroristas al ejército
israelí a los servicios de inteligencia
que anoche completaron una operación
exitosa es un saldo de víctimas grande
para el inicio del año teniendo que el
2022 fue el año más mortífero desde la
segunda intifada con unos 200 palestinos
y 30 israelíes muertos la autoridad
nacional Palestina que administra partes
de discordania y de manera frecuente
brinda inteligencia e Israel había
advertido de consecuencias
a la luz de la repetida agresiones
contra nuestro pueblo y el
incumplimiento de los acuerdos firmados
Incluyendo los de seguridad consideramos
que ahora la coordinación de seguridad
con el gobierno de ocupación de Israel
ya no existe
este anuncio no tiene precedentes la
autoridad nacional Palestina había
amenazado ya con dar ese paso sin
haberlo efectuado
pero Estados Unidos condenó la decisión
el secretario de estado Anthony blinken
tiene previsto visitar Israel Isis
Jordania comienzos de la próxima semana
para discutir medidas de desescalamiento